Dave I understand that you dropped out
of film school I did two years yeah
curious what classes you would have
preferred them to teach you sorry to
bring this up no it's fine I I would
just never do it I don't it's not like I
wanted to learn in that way I just
wanted to to make videos and learn by
myself I'm just like when knowing now
that in around that time YouTube was
just starting to become a thing and you
could find a tutorial on anything with
your troubleshooting something or having
it didn't know how to work a specific
like editing function or a lighting
issue I just wanted to to teach myself
when I hit a roadblock
I just knew how easy it was to find the
answer on the internet and also not go
into debt and also I was very fortunate
to have my best friend was at USC and
was making all these wonderful friends
in film and television and music and I
ended up just kind of mooching off of
his experience really I dropped out of
school and I would hang out with these
dudes and start making videos with them
because they were so talented and funny
and that's it was just such a natural
like yeah I don't need to spend money on
school when I can just do it myself and
I have pretty much everything I need
with a camera and some funny friends
this was for the good neighbor that's a
good neighbor yeah yeah yeah so we
started your neighbor in like 2006 Yeah
right around the time that Kyle
graduated college and I was doing like
freelance editing and I you learned so
much more from just like having a job or
piaying or assistant editing and film is
a very specific world in which I don't
think you really need
go to some school that being said some
film schools are like like a USC which
is so great at developing the community
and like really the relationships that
end up being the thing that truly
becomes the the reason you spent all
that money but all the gear and the
history of film and the lessons you can
learn about you know how to direct the
scene or whatever all that stuff is in
books and on the internet and directors
or actors giving talks and it's just my
opinion that I just don't think film
school is necessary for filmmakers but I
don't want to discourage someone who
really wants to learn that way sure yeah
did you realize that the film
Gracie bear was going to be such an
inspiration for sort of fan of obsessed
filmmakers because it's an incredible
story in itself it's probably one of the
best movies I've seen so far
oh my god and um but it caters to people
who are just obsessed with movies well
we knew we definitely felt that it was a
love letter to storytelling and
filmmaking in the movie-going experience
but you never want to make something
with the expectation of it having that
type of reception I just think that's
unhealthy to to hope for that or expect
that we were just trying to have fun and
make something that we liked and that
maybe our friends liked but yeah we
weren't trying to build any type of
obsession or or you know it's always
nice to hear that people are inspired by
it but I was never thinking like I'm
going to make a film that everyone's
inspired by which is definitely not
everyone but it's very nice to hear that
people it gives people that energy of oh
I want to I'm excited to go make a video
after watching this movie like that
that's a cool feeling so sort of like
the YouTube videos because you never
know when the audience is going to
relate to one of your comedy skits
first is not its hit or miss yeah it's a
again with every internet video we made
even our SNL sketches we're trying to be
the best we can at not catering to any
audiences and just trying to make each
other laugh or each other feel or
whatever it is but yeah the the
repetition of all those videos and that
we've made the hundreds over the years
was so instrumental going into making
this film in this film really is a it
mirrors both Colin and my experience as
best friends who fell in love with
filmmaking together and the movie has a
lot to do about collaborating with the
best friend and following them up with
telling stories so it's a very meta
experience and it's super special yeah
thank you thank you so much
you